did you say ready what's up fool what's
up fool podcast welcome to the Watson
food pockets for everybody out there
what's up boo I'm right here well
jiggles right here
Lisa's right here we have our guest
right here would you do some later
Louise Banuelos the man the myth the
legend the gatekeeper no really
he makes gates your big-ass Venice Beach
bro excuse me it was badass it was tight
just walk around chill you go to park at
Venice Beach or you park at Marina del
Rey
no we parked right there in Venice Beach
we combed around for about 15-20 minutes
you wife although for there were around
the corner from that spot from garden so
you start right there at our Venice
Beach right there where they feel right
back and Joe yeah well we cruise right
there by those courts it right the
street right behind the beach this is
where we part so you walk for a long
time we walk for like four hours that's
a long walk from that area all the way
to Marina del Rey oh you guys will do
that walk to Marina del Rey yeah because
we were really yeah we didn't go that
far
well yeah we went from that area say it
with the same ease garden near the Thai
restaurant you ate that all the way to a
better Beach okay how long is that not
with a kid I think I remember no the kid
I would deal with walk did you ever
imagine monster the kid oh dear we went
twice that I've ever done although
remember about your mountain is i
starved there bro very bad nothing you
guys look we brought we brought food the
second time we bought food or first time
we ate in the car dog what's up bull
bigger men in the house always done a
Martinez mega man Fred
says Rip's what's up fool Richard Medina
was served food Josef Martina what's up
ooh
Melanie Kimberly yo Applejack alia
stevemartina for ronica Floyd what's up
fool
yeah man what's up the first tality we
went to Disneyland or wonderful Six
Flags Magic Mountain we were at my
cousin's house where Oh uh-huh
and that food made like MI and they made
a bunch of huevos a bunch of eggs
potatoes bro but you know I'm a little
kid bad cheese was only made for cheese
like my kids what other kid my skis we
only use cheese for quesadillas or
chilaquiles bro or or enchilada they
would never know what cheese for the
beans no cheese in the eggs
no no they [ __ ] hold down that cheese
bro oh you know what you know what kind
of cheese we use for the bees and cheese
for our eggs we use that Kraft Parmesan
cheese I already pizza you ever make
that pizza in a box yeah I don't know
how like it started but everybody my
family and my cousins whenever they make
tacos like flautas whenever they made
anything that would they will use that
parmesan you know with the craft the
craft
Parmesan cheese it has a little setting
why don't you ever use that chief for
pizzas well I became an adult
oh yeah I thought the men were using for
tacos over here yeah I [ __ ] that [ __ ]
with the cheese yeah a lot cheese
despair or Mexican pretty much problem
my mom does a lot of cheese by my hand
so it's yeah what do you guys have cows
we'll go go go go cheese bar Nashes bomb
dog I don't really care for his house
take you to the Colorado cheese
so fellowmen offal Bloomington look at
cheesier mamita she makes the goat
cheese Farah that is hardened oh yeah
it's hardened that's more like cottage
cheese goat cheese a soft crackers and
[ __ ] I like those fancy restaurants
there God goat cheese they'd put 10
bucks yeah she bought me that you know
so you're so your mom so cheese Rotel no
no she never sold it she just do it for
the family she would sell tamales my
mouth and stuff my grandfather Fernando
Stanton that girl over there right now
[ __ ] know what's in it Oh sue now is
last name a now see hello I'll go at Los
Mochis little channel a record eNOS I
don't know their food made cheese but I
know by 6:00 o'clock in the morning that
we had to buggy the cheese off or
somewhere so somebody in town would make
the steak somebody in town would make
cheese Bo like like real kiss will
fresco went it's a best friend a cheat
and he'll have it like and then dude it
was rather the cheese bag I never see
I'm riding right a rag wait a special
like a little cheese Club yes he lost so
he'll have to cut to two cups into my
list
two buckets of the white bucket smile
and then they'll be like stacked up
chill to it all the way to the top that
will go to where he bought the cheese
bought it and then on the way home he
had customers already lined up so he and
he knew where to go you know like even
if this person was that give me three
[ __ ] you you three get one like every
week you get one right in there because
if I give you three I'm not gonna have
another one for that [ __ ] was
one so he never had enough to make a lot
of money but he had enough to feed
everybody but every little town had a
cheese guy everybody had like a like a
little meat guy dogs all that yeah and
they'll go somewhere to buy a full
[ __ ] homemade
good tortilla oh my god those are the
best dude
I wonder if your grandfather learned
from Germans like those you know the
Germans who were sent to teach Mexicans
how to make cheese oh you didn't make it
he did because what generation was he
was like there in the 30s he was an
adult right 30s 20s yeah I don't know if
he made it but I know that was it was
there and he's to me refried beans white
right hell yeah I never thought I would
like refried white beans man they were
good yeah your mom make northern beans
how those white beans bring them back to
life daughter threw a good blow a little
scoop of butter on top my mom would make
those and throw like a little red for
the chili in there though everybody's
party horn die bro nobody ate him though
war bad for that night shame our pets
only happened twice so you were born in
Mexico fool yeah well I was actually
born well Allah had a really full yeah
and then my parents have a house in
Guadalajara and it is so we would go to
it is you know for pretty much for the
rest of the time well I had it was just
a Hut pretty much you know now they're
there no matter what
yeah they're selling it I I don't know
what what they're doing to it because
they're really next to the buildings now
so who's your mama you got my mom and
dad oh yeah yeah yeah my dad was a the
poor one my mom was the rich one yeah
uh-huh oh she had money how is she rich
her family had money yeah all her family
owned a lot of cattle in and property
and then I know as soon as she got with
my dad they were like yeah you're out
[Laughter]
pretty much no dating they pretty much
chose who the who didn't marry her
daughter bro like that like she can't be
married nobody who's struggling like
were struggling now better now we do
somebody a better man we
struggling wooden use the weenie another
guy go bring us down that's a problem
you go to a dinner then you come over
here brought nobody Nintendo Maury what
they do you know there's only one man
before like now I think I'm rich people
though they regulate bow you marry that
person is like the truck legit marry
anymore hell nah that's why she married
that fool dog yeah but poor we will do
that too huh
what happened poor people do that yeah
this is gonna be hardcore I'm like I
know at at my and my dad's side of the
family they don't like me and my mom's
side of the family they [ __ ] love me
yeah because I'm the only guy that looks
like my grandpa so they're like oh yeah
like they're let go like that like every
time I go is like lay the pictures they
like a like yeah
so how did you make it out here
I actually I heard your story about how
you came and that's pretty much how we
did it tell you had that what happened
yeah bro we came from the water loop you
know we didn't live there it was like a
one day process like we had some buddies
some cousins out here and they let us
burger they look alike are right yeah
yeah how evil I was like five your
brother your brother's 2yb yeah brother
who came to yeah yeah wasn't most of us
only two two of us two to birth yeah
that were born here
the rest were legal came from from sick
I take us well I had a move to where the
first time we gave the first
Pomona oh you landed in Pomona that's a
first town yeah that family there too
yeah yeah like I grew up most most of my
life in Pomona where your mom tell me
your dad's so you we need to call of
Loma
that's why we click to me and Africa's
we were from Pomona yeah but what year
did you glandon
it was like man king bingi maybe nine it
was popping right there oh yeah no yeah
we used to live next to share evil like
they would find a dead body like all the
time yet my friend of like he's not my
friend but I got a grew up in a
neighborhood huh huh
that kind of little Carlos little
Carlitos who will put me with a police
officer in a Pomona during 89 92 93
I forgot shot like dead nah he he live
okay but he was a shooter Pomona like in
school he was a copper Pomona in his 20s
and early 20s and he got he was in a
shootout in Pomona
Pomona the first time I heard it was
hardcore dude like we're like and I'm
thinking okay he could have been an LAPD
but he was a Pomona okay there's no
violence over there they were fresh out
they [ __ ] shot that for what a little
fools brother so he was hard on time
better in everybody
you get free lunch at the park are you
gonna free lunch at poor house I
remember I remember I remember one time
I was seeing this girl and I my friend
here he lives in Pomona and so I go like
hey you want me my friend well goes well
so you can meet him we go there in the
corner of ourselves there's a dead body
and so I was like nothing happens here
is just I know what happened and then
like two weeks later I'm like hey let's
go visit my friend and the dead body in
the same corner brother and then after
that house outside cuz he lived in the
corner house and it was like right on
the sidewalk outside somebody got killed
it shot or stabbed with a shot and then
I remember the cops showed up a little
no yeah the second time and that
happened his his his dead dad comes up
and he sound like you better check your
truck because I think they turns again
in there I was like what I don't know I
never forget I never checked bro but I
was all like wow
[ __ ] Pomona you always been around metal
hotdogs yeah and then you even if even
if I found it with my dad's enemies are
from Jerry of your laughs all of my
Delacorte Wall Street even my grandpa
back in the fifties kid cyber bank is a
living
those gentlemen there forever house in
the fifties oh yeah yeah like back then
is like stupid you say a free lunch at
the park what's up
Pomona come on Long Beach more crazy
Jeff Cooper motoring literally like a
lot of drugs came in the late eighties
huh yeah probably would have any drug
little PCP a little hair away but now
Bama I honestly don't know bro like I've
never tried drugs so I don't never went
out looking for it so I never paid
attention to that I just know the gang
problem might never care for the drug
part you know but I know that there was
a lot of race rights I was walking this
is in the 90s right yeah everybody will
race race instead of Monica and Venice
Beach
no yeah they were like I remember one
time some a group of black guys were
beating up Mexicans and then the next
day the whole school was surrounded by
like 12 Street and all those [ __ ]
gangs and [ __ ] I was like [ __ ] and then
I had to help my friend get we got him
in my car and then we [ __ ] booked it
because he was black or like my cousin
shut down the Pomona PD helicopter went
to ia laugh aloud
I remember that happen bro that [ __ ] in
Riverside to me because I'm like oh no
they sure had a couple of being so crazy
bro and a beard a juvenile and shoot a
helical I know that right yeah yeah I
know the craziest story that happened in
Pomona was this guy was he went up to
the court in Pomona oh and as for and
like told the cop he was lost if you
could help him and as soon as the cop
winning sham right ahead yeah that's how
crazy I got for a while was that a game
dude or what he wanted to be in a gang
they fell dead later on that's what
happens when you're not [ __ ] was this
all made up
[Laughter]
I like the large a you go poo Venice's
finest of it so what's up man so you
grew up a you went to high school where
and Gary high school Gary high school
yeah Pomona Pomona yeah with no leg up
when you start when you start it's good
you know English runner will you picked
it up fast in kindergarten well I picked
up pretty quick in in like first grade
probably I know that for the first year
we had to like take notes you know there
my dad were right for us like he'd be
like this but MLT were right milk he
spoke English better than you guys
thought yeah cuz he was here like two
years prior to us and then he [ __ ]
saved up money to [ __ ] bring his over
you know but yeah I can used to read his
notes and so we were just going to the
the lady our lunch ticket and and the
note that's how [ __ ] crazy
we're talking about earlier about when
we were kids like now matter they are
like you can buy cigarettes if you're 18
years old you can't drink you're 21 but
when I was a little boy I'm like it but
not my mom but I know the other parents
they were right their sons a note please
give to Utah 40 ounces
agua and a pack of cigarettes in diapers
yeah we were just yesterday we took we
took notes for my friend's mom for
cigarettes please give so and so Lisa
earned not me but is my friend's name a
pack of Marlboro Lights whatever and on
credit to hear stories I never got to do
it but so you want just go there you
learn English and you would you guys you
know high school what happened
yeah I graduated from high school then I
went to like a year of Community College
will you make me a fool come on
[Laughter]
actually I did electronics because I
[ __ ] olbes and that once and the time
demolish the the gate motors you know
the self openers never coming they were
coming out oh yeah also I was like
oh if I if I learn how to do this I'll
get him I'll get a raise and and I and I
learned how to do it but those classes
were horrible why you didn't understand
what the [ __ ] you don't really learn
much gone to a trade school instead of
committee yeah that's right yeah cuz man
when it's all booked setting the theory
of it yeah and so I I i hanged out with
a teat a college professor that lived a
block away from where my parents live
mm-hmm and he he pretty much showed me
at his at his shop oh so he was actually
practiced actually yeah you went to
Chafee your mounts at mount sac the
shocking I know
no like mount sac was like and this how
stupid I was I was like all right no cuz
because I used to play basketball for
them for the for the high school thing
don't be like a Mexican immigrant please
do vote up a basketball bro maybe a
half-court played 7 or 7 bro the whole
half-court it feels like you can't even
you can't even you can't even dribble
bro you just keep passing I thought
Glassell Park yeah man that's a pork
really [ __ ] my size half poor play
five on five yeah oh yeah oh yeah but
and then I remember I was like alright
I'll go to mount sac and I'll I'll play
basketball there and then I'll go to
UCLA people eat you the first day I got
there I like fight this like I couldn't
even guard the girls were you varsity in
high school yeah in basketball yeah I
know okay what I won back back then I
and like I used to be able to like
barely touch the rim like don't belie
dawg really we had a good ass layup he
pass well or what the [ __ ] had a mad
jumper huh I had a Meno post up game
damn bro that you play soccer Boas
cashews or basketball did you play with
stocking was cleats or [ __ ] his cashews
I can tell you a funny story blacks the
payless shoes yeah they believe that
black that black staining [ __ ] I know
dog where'd you say five foot three
Center no mommy play with a volleyball
it's a funny story about the shoes dog
yeah so you play with basketball with
well your little ass payless shoes
there's my nose I had actually and go
tell my dad to buy me some better shoes
because they will leave us skid mark you
play forever lady wasn't my choice and
the coach wouldn't let me play unless I
I had better shoes so hakeem olajuwon
saying is the shoes your shoes were
making a new three-point line I couldn't
afford my keys so hakeem olajuwon had
Spalding on David Solomon pay less and
so I bought the Spalding and they were
working I was like [ __ ] yeah yeah Kimo
Olajuwon and another Steve Stephon
Marbury yeah Stephon Marbury had their
own shoes at Target and could they might
they wanted the kids to be affordable
Shaq had him at Walmart yeah yeah yeah
League years right jacket at killing it
with Paul D Paul D yeah cuz they used to
copy Nikes like like you know how Nike
had that shoe that had air on the side
all across then
Spalding would have 34 on it okay
because the 34 they couldn't put a
larger one on there or something
so you played out usually wired up you
wanna you play our basketball for how
many years in your school I like I
started playing basketball since I was
like in fifth grade or something like
that and then after that it was like
because we used to play marbles any Kazi
yeah and then I used to be mad because I
used to play with the Cambodians and
they would like this Marvel with the
whole hyung and in Jung we have a tiny
farm and it will get the marble and put
it on the index on the middle finger
yeah because well you didn't you use
your thumb bow to flick it
yeah yeah yeah Mexicans do like this and
then they were [ __ ] every Mesmer
so after yeah like I went through phases
like marbles power-ups far less
forgiving about tops roll you know spin
a top oh yeah but not not that much I'm
pretty whitewashed him over here I was
thinking I think I have two uncles that
look like Hammett my Florida family it
was cool yeah yeah I'm like super white
I don't know me oh I'm sure German or so
they probably pogs you had not that many
betrayed them and she used to staple
them no problem thinking right
originally they came from like dude up a
dream yeah work with all those kids it
would not pogs but there was like think
that will come on of some sort of yeah
okay that's what they used to flip over
but by the time we got him they started
making [ __ ] Slammers it looked like
you know those metal and there's [ __ ]
there's so so dumb a little stupid man
when like and I hate it with like I
would buy our soda and you know part of
a contest then I look at the tip using a
loser like [ __ ] I wasn't in the contest
nothing we try to win [ __ ] or
what time we had a thing cause I like
Pepsi I had a thing we gotta spell Pepsi
so everybody could like bottle cap P II
don't know I should've been at that
[ __ ] cop in the game yeah he got
busted on later make a movie I saw the
movie bro you see McDonald's - I read
that article the other day I'm so
interesting that's [ __ ] crazy and
were you one of those annoying kids that
carried a basketball or a soccer ball
no I had like an old basketball so it
was like too embarrassing to carry that
shittily leather huh little coming up ya
look good at balls would bounce boogie
too
you just can't grip them know I had a
sweatband that's how [ __ ] stupid I
was that was Michael Jordan like oh I
remember I went to go see Michael Jordan
IMAX movie bro based you know not beige
yeah they actually had a documentary I
liked about him and his like yeah hit
the science of like his his throws and
everything - oh like his last two
championships little Giga pets giggles
oh yeah I remember my sister like that
crap give a little dog and she gonna
feed him every day and I know how well
bro
I will feed them I hear like a GGO dog
on a little phone like a little dog and
hit me like jumping around and he'll
patter but my policy my brother overfeed
on my shades so he could wake up in the
morning dad uh so uh Joey left that
started up comedy happy well you're a
basketball more stand-up comedy no III
love Santa oh you're a funny guy in high
school no I didn't even talk to people
quiet
like I I literally got laid like at the
age of 25
wow man welcome to him bro you gotta
leave it at a [ __ ] bathroom bro yeah
the bathroom OH - OH - Ivan I've been
under a row with this pool table story I
was drunk tofu one time we did a show in
San Jose and uh that where I saw him -
is that Hosea brighten up for in a
[ __ ] power room and and two old ladies
were talking it was like I was the gray
show and you know but I drank 14
Jameson's done and like 12 beers I was
[ __ ] up and I don't remember doing it
all right I just when I was [ __ ] up
anybody go for it she came over the edge
they disappeared and then like in the
morning they'd if economy that they need
a ride I guess they got I do remember
those old lady they were probably at
that time my early 50s huh mm-hmm
I don't know what happened like whatever
we were talking and I was gonna try to
do nothing
I'm not gonna mention the other
comedians and it was like same age and I
guess we're good girls they're big
you're oh that box take what you ain't
good at anything is you're here because
you're looking for
do you see what you saw for God I do
what that's it
so I did a background there the whole
night there that's what you gotta do I
don't whip nothing out though man that's
a harassment [ __ ] they're like VIP that
I'm nice too huh
what tell people ma'am I'm a different
generation for me to me I'm more like
God and would you [ __ ] that she I will
yeah me too late I'll quiet you're
looking up jiho's videos they were
raided out do you never remember that
yeah yeah what were that the beer run
Bobby showed up Oh at the em road oh the
F forest right in a restaurant in the
corner dude it was that dude people look
at buy me shots they put us in a [ __ ]
shitty hotel
I [ __ ] overdosed and like there was
cows there you know I slept through that
you let the Grim Reaper go dead body
just a little boy Ice Cube will be yeah
what if you're their body hi wait right
here yeah so what we're gonna eat or
what happened bro after that a night
when you saw me I brought you you ran
away
well when I saw what he whipped it out
oh no I was because I was laughing
because he's banging it against the
[ __ ] boys like a second here on a
post bro like
I do not remember that [ __ ] no III left
cuz I was like [ __ ] I don't drink
soda well you know you don't even think
it out now
never drink Wow yeah so we'll the first
thing they tell of Comedy
Kylie were at Liam's Liam's wrong and
then four and then Carlos Loma told me
about what coyotes then I went to
volcano DS or was it late and Wednesday
night and then I get a call from you on
Friday that to pick you up in like
Palmdale or some [ __ ] no impossible
I thought we had made before then no no
I remember that gig man I will I did a
show over with Sebastian Cetina or Eric
Blake but I was in the middle of nowhere
bro
I don't know I was like man oh what a
little time when when I'm I was doing so
many drugs that I have nobody to call
bro like like I figured that like I was
gambling bro thinking I figure you know
what I'm just trying to people uglies
chick to hopefully get a ride home that
was my plan dude yeah but I think I
didn't get buzzed enough to whip it out
yeah man it was a Christmas show bro and
I remember man like little by little I
was leaving and everybody everybody what
you're gonna stay call yeah go to we
then he got later later there was no
uber or no tea bro then you showed up
right those we say I don't know I
thought we made before that
no no oh I play with friends on MySpace
please know Carlos mama gave you my
number cuz when you come here like it
was so full I'm like who's this you're
like it's Felipe
Carlos gave me your number and I was
like alright and then you're like I can
give me a ride and I was like yeah yeah
I pick you up like it pop off spring
somewhere oh I feel far there huh I took
it to LA and you paid me with the CD bro
little garden for now I don't I wish I
had I had a collector's item this fool
will pay me with a CD or a [ __ ] and it
was the same shirt and same CD yeah I
wrote for that man
but I remember we're driving to go to
hate that they stopped somewhere what
the [ __ ] stop somewhere where because
I'm a security guard this trip boring we
stop with this trip bar yeah yeah hello
everybody yeah yeah a little while yeah
cuz that was a door guy at the strip
joint at that time well then with a
strip bar spirit behind strip joint
right and a Mona Mona Mona
that's crazy won't my drugs and [ __ ]
yeah but we went there right after the
show but kind of late but also a lot of
people there man and that would annoy
everybody there yeah like I'll try to
find we'd probably - yeah I I know at
that place Sugar Shane Mosley is that
used to be there all the time
really yeah he's from Pomona /a mostly
came in and did you know Sugar Shane now
he came in and and told us was that not
to let his bat in because he was
spending a lot of money bro really yeah
that's the only time I talked to the
back okay she gave me a ride home all
the way to Boylston huh yeah in downtown
Wow
and then you're like hey come Saturday
I'll give you a spot I walk coyotes and
I got a spider I'm gonna pay you
I think I'm here a t-shirt huh
no I think it was like five bucks or
sound like new right new cover you know
and at that time like every comic was
like you gotta pay dues bro
so what happened after that you did that
say I remember you did that set but that
meant they were picking me up bro that's
the first time you pick me up yeah that
was the first time I picked you be real
before and after that yeah picked you up
a lot of times after that couple of
times I remember one time we went to San
Manuel and you had a backpacking and
they had like a table full of food and
you just filled up your backpack though
that Factory
yeah brah we with me you and I think
Craig shoemaker was there yeah yeah and
another and Danny Cortes or cortex that
you need to do seeing our commercials
he's finally dude but but there were
older comedians and I remember out no it
was no no they're not the shoemaker it
was that guy who used to have a comment
here to have a show but his show got
cancelled and then The Drew Carey Show
blew up oh man it was a he was a no
color for Chicago he's funny guy brought
here to have a joke about arm yeah about
I being an astronaut the ferment of Moon
I know what that guy he was there and
then he picked me up there what happened
there did you take me literals there
either
no I met you like a train station or
something like that because that was at
the at the Ontario improv and you hit me
up you're like hey bro what you doing
I'm like I'm at the Ontario improv and I
was just there hanging out and you were
like egging let's go to a laugh factory
I was like all right where you at
and I want to pick you up oh I want I
will have the train station right there
at bow before you get to a tour improv
ah yeah yeah Montclair now with Mike
Harris in Ontario so you people be to me
to the Laugh Factory and fill up all the
food or a backpack let me tell you that
food right then that [ __ ] check let's
take a mug bro broke for broke to I get
that check no yeah so what happened out
there I just remember like I kept
telling you like a let's roll bro why
because I have a friggin gambling
problem yes because I had a gambling
problem - as soon as I stopped drinking
yeah and I stopped smoking weed and I
stopped doing crack and PCP and
everything right yeah I was sober I
don't know what happened I went to the I
was at a show once and then No
this girl I remember though this girl
and the the headlight no trying to be
with her I think with Willie or I don't
know what happened but I'm I remember
the headliner he gave me a hundred
dollars to stay away so the girl won't
see me or look or so he could be with
her so he gave me a hundred dollars and
I went to the casino and I [ __ ] lost
I see about it but I have a problem too
so your problem with blackjack or slider
slots excites me and I I was sweating
birds because when you're fairly but you
have to kick it with him like you like
next to him and without doing nothing
cuz everybody wants to take pictures
with you and I was like [ __ ] if I sit
down at the [ __ ] atmosphere yeah and
so I just kept like I was like you would
think me and forget Felipe for a couple
and the thing about the gambling as long
as I don't sit down I'm your cool yeah
I'm cool like I'm not like oh [ __ ]
there's the casino he's just nice thing
down that's the problem
what the vault you ever lost a thousand
bucks in a day yeah like a night me I
lost that much but then I had no more
money and I had like rings bro having a
gold ring and had a gold bracelet and
her logo pinky after I left [ __ ] go I
like I like I saw that up I don't know
if I had a phone but I looked up in here
no pages pawnshops and I saw that pawn
shops over the helpers at eight and I
saw that at 6 or at a [ __ ] a I'm
gonna go to that Danny's get a coffee
your little eggs and wait right and I
only have my earlier I was gambling
right there brokers I had enough money
to put ten dollars and make it home but
instead of he's doing that stupid idea
I'll use the ten dollars to chew her
dailies and get a coffee like a loser
bro and I waited then that [ __ ] open bro
I got $60 for everything [ __ ] raped
you for that yeah and I went back
oh I thought like a [ __ ] I finally
kill him myself dog and I [ __ ] um I
made you just enough gas to them the
same area where we're all waiting for a
pawn shop I mean a little further bro I
was a foot of that cat it further uncle
and [ __ ] like a bomb bro he made him
read the gas hey could you help me out
straight up somebody hook you up it took
forever bro let's agree I'm a liar but I
will know the line man whatever gonna
say man I she taught me a lot of laughs
I got enough money to make it to my
friend's house and then my friend she
wanted to go gamble and in [ __ ] I
don't know where somewhere by Lake
Havasu AE so I took my rent money
brought I went what happened yeah wants
200 bucks I pay my rent within it but
next week it was broke again but I
didn't sleep the whole three days I bet
my friend took off to sleep and I was in
at the table snowing and I was getting
Chancellor's shoulder that's cold it's
cold it's going in and then finally left
but in sleep I was bad dude I was like I
caused the same problems for myself as a
drug addict I caused the same problem
the sober person was gambling now you
were well yeah cuz you're like [ __ ] I
just wasted my [ __ ] bail money you
guys get high up that [ __ ] or what's it
give you no because that's one of the
strongest reinforcements in psychology
is when it's an intermittent schedule
when you don't know when it's gonna
happen when the reward has come
surprising is you know the social media
works on the same level to like you see
that little notification and it gives
you some sort of pleasure to check it
and see what see what it's about but it
went then there's time that goes by with
no notifications and you don't know when
the next one's gonna come and so you see
it every time you you know you want to
click on it every time but gambling is
the same way you feel like it's got to
come now now if I sit here long enough
I'm gonna get that win [ __ ] I think if I
would have won the first time when I
lost that money dude I would have been
on that [ __ ] so it's you're aware of
your win yeah well I want I want some
some couple of times yeah yeah that's
why you keep going back cuz you win
Willie Barcena what Willie no I mean
really never really never you're too
hardcore probably why so you pick me up
you pick me up at the at the casino it
was another time I remember that time
Wow a long time ago
ya know yeah there's there were a couple
of times that I would pick you you pick
me off box double time yeah one time
yeah what was that you you kept telling
me to like a just go over here cuz I was
like now I have to take you home and you
were like hey stop here and I was like
now I got to go back to work and you're
like [ __ ] what's told me what's up come
out to LA to [ __ ] kill roaches right
now dog so what happened bro well that
one of my drugs I don't know where you
want to go but I remember when I dropped
you off you were like that's why you're
never gonna get booked that mad bro no
they tell everybody with that look in
his eyes like it's like so well yeah
[ __ ] up you were [ __ ] up you know
and it was like hard to to to to control
you when you were so controlling him now
yeah well you were sober at least you'd
be like yeah you're right bro some
reason we would even Walker your knees
what happened you dropped me off at the
house or where yeah I dropped you off at
the house and then I poked it back home
and then and then like under on the way
back I just remember I would get text
messages you know it's like were you I
like well you read and I was like I'm
going home bro like what I thought you
were coming and
probably texting someone else and then
they started being like wow the next for
Texas or like that
but I cooked a larger drug uh I didn't I
didn't know you drank at that time I
knew you were I walked up to uh I saw
Luis bollo ellos bro like after one last
comment standing like row 2012 the
[ __ ] bus to me I'll give you in a way
bro city yeah they ran out of material
dollar and I remember I would like call
I would call him [ __ ] feel like dude
this was always on dude always on the
team dog always but yeah again but yeah
and then I saw you had that that room in
the room no oh oh it's County that the
church yeah
the deadly place at Roscoe Roscoe Roscoe
yeah that was the one time I saw him
after the are you small grass cigarettes
yeah I smell smoke yeah make that your
gamble no I don't wait for my lot of
things bro it's Tom huh bro little by
sit back and not really because I live
far away from everything now bro ya know
in Menifee like there's nothing after
there was that I think you still blew me
do some of their by Temecula
okay but you don't that Club right so
macula yeah yeah yeah which one I'll
Pechanga to with Django yeah loosen your
runs at yeah have you ever done none of
those shows over there in El Centro Papa
chulo I did it once now but you know who
did it with Carlos Lama bro I remember
we're coming back is Farha bro
and therefore you know you know how
there's that checkpoint yeah oh yeah
he's not like if you have a warning let
me if you have an arrest warrant let me
know I was like no I don't have an
arrest warrant so like all right [ __ ] I
don't want get arrested and so we get
there and they're like asking for our
[ __ ] and they go like alright can you
get they told me that can you step out
the car I was like alright and they took
all of loma can you step out the car and
then they go like yeah you need to take
the car because he's thinking whether
they who stays like this back home and I
got home and I get a phone call from
Carl's luma he's all okay come pick me
up bro like where you at he said like
I'm over here at Indio so I go to I
Drive all the way to India I'm like when
you add he's all like at the motel 6 and
I get there and I call him and I'm like
hey where you at this mood pops out of
the bushes now because they were hoping
that we get more people to so they could
send everybody to LA in [ __ ] really yeah
what's all these crooked ass what
happens it again they took them off that
date supposed to be day like an hour
later they were like hey we're gonna let
you go we're gonna see if we could catch
up to your buddy
so you give you a ride home but I was
already [ __ ] like too far gone that
they just left him at India you know and
then he called me up and I went to go
pick him up at India
what's that Border Patrol CHP Border
Patrol yeah laughs I coulda had me
rolling though cuz he jumped out of the
rushes just clean those out but hey Rose
you said that you had work went to a gig
what time of your truck roll night right
yeah well yes I pulled over we got
pulled over and at that time I didn't
have a license I would just why cuz I
was I was like never had time to get it
bro yeah and I would give my brother's
name cuz he had an idea and everything
and we lookin like a fool tell him like
wicked 10 minutes before who call dog
your mom oh yeah my mom she's all like
hey where you going because we need the
truck
and I was like oh we'll be back right
now and you would just take off like
back then I didn't do recording in San
Jose yeah we were yeah that was the day
yeah we went to San Jose with this guy
and then we got pulled over and then on
the way new team right there on the fire
was the bridge we got pulled over on the
bridge food we had us on the bridge tie
first of all yeah right no no no right
right on the 118 right there yeah on the
bridge and then that's when the iPhone
came out because it's full didn't have
no no I D
who takes a picture of Louise anybody it
made him leave his a fingerprint to on a
piece of paper like he's all who could
drive this and if I can Alfred doesn't
want to give us all I don't have an ID
either and so I and forgetting I didn't
even get paid that day do that full
jacked or a stop [ __ ] oh yeah
BB Bobby oh yeah [ __ ] and you went
back with yourself right later on yeah
all the time
these fools are happy doggies that I
said hit him a little yeah that they're
offering me $1,500 to come back and do a
lowrider show that there you go no I did
the improv like after that I was like
did you headliner you do this party no I
I was a feature I was a feature in know
who for couch and I remember I was all
happy because I saw David Beckham and I
was like oh [ __ ] you know how they put
you in that night so very much yeah and
David Beckham was in the elevator was
like holy [ __ ] and I was all excited bro
I guess that's drug with with with
athletes not celebrities
yeah and then [ __ ] after that I was
all like texting my mom and texting my
dad guess what I [ __ ] ran into soccer
you let your dad like soccer yeah yeah
so he started alliums and then from
there while you try to meet him people
there who told you where all the rooms
are at yeah and dad and and and chuckle
monkey you remember chuckle monkey or
the webpage yeah a webpage that you
would go there and then that was goes go
to the places if they were closed I
would just go to the next one now they
got the comedy beer oh yeah
so what so you were shy you didn't
really talk to anybody when you were in
high school and all that you never
thought about being a commute nobody
ever told you like you were funny as a
younger kid like what made you decide
I'm gonna try comedy I'm gonna be in
comedy I want to do this
I saw Rodney Dangerfield his special and
I saw him sweating and and I was like
wow if this [ __ ] nervous [ __ ] could
do it I could do it yeah and then I went
to lambs that like that same day but I
didn't know that was his act
no like I was like what the [ __ ] and
then after that I was like all right
went to Liam's and I remember I did the
same day I was Rodney Dangerfield did
that because I was like oh well he did
that joke about how he's all like I I
was driving home and I saw a man running
naked I did that joke and that was the
only joke I did would be laughs just
Mikey told me like after that he saw
like hey you know that's somebody else's
job like what yeah Norris paid back I
know and then and then after that I was
like oh you have to ride your own [ __ ]
but back then we had a lot of the mics
now there's not that many yeah everybody
wants to get paid now oh yeah we going
up every day no no back then back then
yeah every day I would go up and I gotta
go to Liam's on Monday Monday Tuesday
yeah
they had the open mic on Monday and then
be our cheese wasn't she yeah that's all
the Inland Empire right yeah yeah
although there was upland yeah and then
I would go to work I owed ease and then
I would go to Harley's and then Fridays
I think I would go to the Hollywood
improv used to hang never saw Sunday
right differently there trypsin had I
don't know horrible time oh oh yeah yeah
yeah that one [ __ ] bar that they
would pay you with drinks if you were
funny they would give you a drink
yeah threw up the well West Covina dog
yeah if the owner like to you he would
give you a drink
that was your payday yeah now now
everybody wants everything quick bro you
know yeah like people like now like and
I don't do it as much as I used to but
now you're here people like you go like
wow you mean I I'm gonna drive to Palm
Springs for $10 foot know like [ __ ] I
used to [ __ ] drive to San Jose for
$10 for ass free CD yeah
Oh drive to LA to do three minutes don't
exactly you know like people complain
too much I know my my first time I got
paid like a real money I was a gig at
Bakersfield bro 60 bucks
that guy picked me up in a van he picked
the ball up comedian in a band
it took us to [ __ ] he took in a pill
trip we tell about Donald's he went to
Bakersfield
we did the show after the show he drove
us all back to our cars an hour late and
give her $60 damn it's crazy because uh
the first
yeah the first gig was Papa chulos and I
can remember I was like what I might get
twenty five [ __ ] dollars holy [ __ ]
yeah yeah you're like what oh [ __ ]
like come on be like I am gonna make it
[Laughter]
but yeah like now used to perform law
every day not every day like he did he
did the show there at uh with us I do
three times a week now because I worked
it worked it's only one time that we're
talking like outsider I think I'll tell
Walker yoli's yet told me that you were
gonna go work so when you got got robbed
outside your house yeah in Pomona yeah
what happened my boss came in to pick us
up and this he we had all the tools
there and that carp came right behind
him got off with guns and they were like
it we gotta take the tools and there was
nothing we could do we're like all right
they go I'm gonna [ __ ] die for no
tools would you do after that go about
you sleeping anymore work no we would go
back to the shop and get the tools again
yeah we had like like they had
everything like we have to go to work
[ __ ] mad cuz we got Jeff Moniz crazy
huh
what's up bull upcoming shows imma be in
Lubbock Texas tonight August 24th
Lubbock Texas Lorado Texas August 25th
Brea August 30 to temper the second
Labor Day weekend and Brea
Improv Atlantic City New Jersey
September 7th at the Borgata Washington
DC September 8th at National Harbor
casino also coming up in September Las
Vegas Laughlin Lexington Kentucky and
Springfield Massachusetts
check out Philippa WorldCom's last tour
for all upcoming shows and ticket
informational pause podcast shirts are
on sale now at Philippians WorldCom
slash shop we also have tote bags and
reduce the prices of some of the older
shirts and you can buy the digital
download under lady my latest album for
five bucks translated here shows
September 9th in Pasadena with flock one
Rizzo and check out my IG and September
11th and Riverside it's not gothic
that's gotta be fellas jokes
what's up full brain improve September
2nd that Sunday blewi12 a spot
yeah man I got you dog you do like five
minute you got five minutes 35 25 35
yeah what are your favorite jokes about
I love your comedy because it's very
like deadpan but it's hard at the same
time like you're like you're [ __ ]
could you lay my TC he's [ __ ]
cutting-edge a funny dude it's kind of
deadpan right and mixed with the like
shocking yeah little silly stuff to you
know show coming up that's right brother
next week huh Sunday yeah yeah next next
Thursday kicks off Freya it's almost
sold out yeah so lovely everyone is big
at 550 550 so if we had a second so you
could do both all right no problem
little bit it'll be me if you need a lot
of people on Sunday
oh yeah on ear okay Rodrigo Matt Walker
what's his face maybe Thursday no I
think we talked about him on Sunday too
hmm and then Matt won something
that's all right do it okay cool then
where I could take him off and put the
weights on work it out
cool yeah and then the feature that is
that day there's no feature dad it's
just it's all right in Saturday or
Friday and Saturday is Matt Fulcher
Matt forearms are full map will try full
charge no charge
what's up fool she doing that a righty
matter what yeah a lot of writing like I
like writing more now then then I used
to recommend I would get tired like
nothing but boring you know like now I
don't get bored as much and I used to
get out that spread like you know how
have you read something you're like AHA
he's not gonna work later
how do you felt the first time you said
one of your original joke that you
thought about and he had a big laugh the
first time the first I felt I feel good
but then I like you know that joke that
you go like oh honey if I would have
done a different it would have been
funnier and that's how it went and then
I think I used it once and then I
stopped using it because it was like a
stupid-ass joke
oh the joke it was about how I had I
can't even I can't even succeed in my
dreams like I had a dream that I was in
the movie Grease but I was just the back
dancer yeah that was the whole joke and
then after that job instead of the star
he dreams instead of his jury in his
dreams he's not this that's like you as
a comic like the people like because a
lot of people get offended now oh yeah
oh GG bro like I'm pretty sure one of
your one of your jobs are so funny I'm
pretty sure people because what's going
on people might be offensive but I think
hilarious like God it's not like the old
days
that show you do about relationships
yeah
fashion yeah yeah hey ladies if you got
with me I'm old fashioned I'm gonna pull
out the share for you I'm gonna open the
door for you here your flowers yeah give
me flowers eight maybe once in a while
you're gonna get a beating but that's
because I'm old fashioned because you
don't expect a shape and the way he
talked any counsel are you gonna get a
little meaty because I'm Oh fascinating
about the roses [ __ ] yeah like like
people on have like after like Oh have
you personally clear [ __ ] everybody
on Instagram or Felipe's offensive I
thought this was a safe place oh my god
yeah what's the OT M's
other than Mexicans those ones from born
in the East LA oh yeah
what's up fool yeah shows coming up yeah
September 9th [ __ ] and then we got the
evil of Joe September 11th in Riverside
and a sucker Tigers cafe and will
because he and you were there with a lot
of fights you two have been in Leo's are
what time yeah well you're in a car
today what time with a bunch of
comedians no no tell me but he took it
like I saw him so he told me you said
that right die dog that fool sucked up
normal get to a fight you know I got I
got Intel finally I know some some guy
was talking and he wouldn't shut up
throughout the whole night
uh-huh and I just told I can't shut up
bro and then he got off again tough and
when he came up he pushed me and then I
clocked them and then knocked him out
[ __ ] dope the Man of Steel over here
though and then Carlos Toma comes over
was funny because like we we were we're
trying to help him bro
like that fool was talking [ __ ] about
some regulars and cholos and well he was
on stage we were trying to get those
cellos like keep him busy over here with
us
and we told him I can't just go out the
other door and that [ __ ] land over
came over where we were at and he said
like hey later guys and then he bucked
it and then the guy [ __ ] those guys
followed them and well the guy started
slapping him and Carlos Slim was
blocking and the guy tell him like eight
the more you block the more I'm gonna
hit you so just take it like a man
and that will put his arms down and I
got him right in the face he took it
like us cuz the next day no but the next
day like I went to go get revenge yeah
18 bro no I went because I saw their
cars and I'm like I'm not [ __ ] ki
those cars yeah and then they saw me and
then by the end they were all [ __ ]
friends and [ __ ] he was talking [ __ ]
about their dad some people just don't
know how to take jokes I guess man you
know and there was those stupid wannabe
tough cholos that yeah not real yeah
like they [ __ ] punk people because
people think they're cholos but if
someone really steps up to him they'll
be like no [ __ ] ain't punkin no
gangsters yeah yeah tell this fool about
the the wrestling matter the
why in pomona dog those uh the wrestling
why no no at the Boys and Girls Club
they used to have wrestling every
Saturday by Sylvester right and so we
would go every every day we're gonna be
Saturday because it was every Saturday
and I remembered the they brought this
guy from Mexico right and the he was on
the radio and the guys are talking [ __ ]
about everybody like all the Mexicans
that are here are low pitches they ran
from their hometown you're like it's a
we're all like [ __ ] this room we take
rocks and we're gonna throw it at them
and they chose to [ __ ] book it you
know and then one time we went and we
got there we we got we got to sit in the
front and this guy gets on top of the
turnbuckle to jump outside and the guy
[ __ ] moved and lands on my brother
bro well he was part of like 15 2014
what happened nothing we're just like
what the [ __ ] trying to [ __ ] help me
[ __ ] like back then like knowing with
two people and everybody [ __ ] like if
I look at Rodrigo wrong he could sue me
super whacking it out bro yeah [ __ ]
used to have like all this [ __ ] crazy
stuff they used to have it at the end of
Swami - in Pomona radome on Chris
Jericho went there once and what are you
serious yeah we didn't know but man
there cuz he kept talking about it when
you were working at a strip bar
well the craziest [ __ ] you seen Shane
Mosley's father do he had a he had he
had the two girls picked like as soon as
he got there those girls would get it
like if you're getting a - from those
girls they would get up and leave you
like they didn't give a [ __ ] if you
didn't pay cuz then we're gonna go get
their money over there but that fool I
remember one time we had a time to stop
spanking him because they like he like
this girl shoulders like maybe he did
forgive me no hand mark really
and then we had service come here meet
how do we get some sugar he was he was a
real nice guy because that's the word
she would like give us like $20 yeah
funny
now cuz we used to walk him because
everybody knew which everybody knew him
so like we had to welcome to his car
oh the PD should you saw at the strip
bar though people having sex well they
pay you to look at the way I wasn't I
never went into the the private lap
dances allowed to go in there huh no
because she doesn't like I know I like
you would hear like people screaming
like another condom [ __ ] yeah because
they had to clean like they had a guy to
clean yeah I thought worst job ever huh
yeah like I was the guy at the door you
know you weren't the jizz mop around no
[ __ ] now hell no and I used to I got
that job because I used to like you know
they have two gates yeah and they had
motors and I would [ __ ] up the motors so
they would have to [ __ ] for you call
me and I'd be like alright I'll go fix
it but I don't want to work I just want
to be the door guy
today and it'll be like alright cool and
then I would go fix them real quick and
so I never [ __ ] did the dirty jobs
you never went in there and got lap
dances
no it's like before that yeah you see I
used to before I got the job I used to
go there a lot you know for lap dances
but it's a waste of money now
yeah like now that I think about I
probably would have been a millionaire
bro
that is slots together huh yeah I
remember one time I went to this trip it
was my birthday I was like 21 bro
and I went and then that your [ __ ]
gaming like and that was all in one
hankies make you bottle uh yeah Rowan
and like okay because that was a virgin
and you know how Mexican parents are
they like suck it's hot or whatever
ah
they like I had like a couple of hippies
here I would walk out proud like to show
my house yeah but not there any crazy
haven't had that strip joint I know one
time it's all sounds pretty crazy the
craziest the craziest one I wasn't there
but a guy got got shot inside and now
like they turned the guy away and then
he came back with the gun and he shot up
the joint and then and then I think he
killed the guy at the arc oh he was all
over the nose it's closed now that strip
club isn't existing he does yeah I used
to go there break the gate - no I go
there because you know people yeah like
I know the the Saint Oh guys I still
work there really I feel met those guys
yeah you did and now trust me like it's
crazy how a lot of people [ __ ] like
you even my dad knows you bro yeah my
dad he's always like yeah when you start
doing those commercials for the car yeah
yeah yeah he's unlike me awfully bad
yeah you don't get with him it's funny
after he did that commercial so many
like regular working-class Spanish dudes
wanted to know how he got into acting
how'd you get in that commercial yep the
guys selling fruit on the beach Timmons
ah how do you get in commercials because
I want to get it covered my friend angel
when you say you're the commercial he's
not like he's the only guy I guess paid
to not to drive the [ __ ] and you know
what I had to show my license to show
the clean driving record yeah I couldn't
go through were easy but everybody Larry
gave me a riser that's true away he's in
the back
but like a lot of people like I know a
lot of people are listening to the
podcast yeah they're comics they're
always like do you really know Rodrigo
or yeah like talking about me yeah -
fine this I did agate and this girl that
went to high school with us she told me
she's all like I know you're not really
bad I heard him on the podcast talking
about you like all right but ya know ya
freaking there's a lot of people that I
know I listen to your your with Joe
Rogan yeah
oh yeah [ __ ] Joe Rogan that [ __ ] you
biggest [ __ ] now his whole his whole
office the gym I remember when I first
started doing comedy that home and see
ya
Joe Rogan should happen blew up yeah and
he was at the Hollywood improv and I
mean Carlos long ago they're all [ __ ]
fanboys now you can we take a picture we
[ __ ] enjoyed what you did we [ __ ] him
and see a piece of [ __ ]
take a picture with his real nice man he
does it like a Joe Rogan at the point of
his life you know where everything's
cool you know like he doesn't want you
know he don't want more here one less
he's except his life man and you know I
love people that he'd help like in a
Comedy Store there were not been as
popular without Joe Rogan hell yeah and
he had put people on the map that
wouldn't not been in a map because of
him and he took a lot of good people who
real Joe Rogan like ideas here Tom
Segura yovan I know you made it when
when I heard you on the under yeah no
Carolla podcast that's like my favorite
podcast yeah you did some work for us
yeah I did have a welding jobs room yeah
but therefore when you made it there I
was like ah
[ __ ] believe that because that will
call you right yeah yeah
supposed to be on again Daggett yeah I
suppose be on again recently
what's up fool we're gonna have release
button your nose back bro
oh there's a lot of more chapters with
this fool dog like to call that for sale
with yes in your right yeah you're with
Butler yeah I think you can find the net
yeah but they don't look anything alike
or anything cuz I don't hear I know the
other guy that were with the comedian
see you mentioned he like a horrible
DeNiro impersonation right just Mikey oh
thank you yeah Bob as prior fool what's
your email bro Instagram I know I have
an Instagram
everybody want some gates done it'll be
the peaches what is it bro Vanilla's
wrought iron works on instagram and hit
me up there but all those rod iron work
and what if we wanted to get it on or
less yeah I don't wanna do a door for me
well we yeah it's at least bundles right
here I know which is the one that you
post your gates on for yeah no I got rid
of all that bro oh here we go
you don't exist you beat your neighbor
up huh
somebody said oh that's the more beat up
your neighbor Oh remember tell my story
oh my gosh table full podcast that you
very much for listening guys I was gonna
go do a meaty one on Universal Brisbane
you know gotta go put a gate up I do
once though so the homie right here
you better in angel angel if they want
thank you bro